hi everyone today I'm here with who
might be a familiar face it's Diana from
physics girl hello thanks for being on
my channel we thought that today we'd do
a bit of an exam unboxing which is you
know a common thing around here but
we're going to look at another very old
exam so we have here the MIT entrance
exam from 1876 and we're just going to
look at the geometry section of it now
Diana makes for an interesting addition
to this video because she actually went
to MIT there's an MIT graduate so it'll
be interesting to see if you know she
can pass the entrance test I got in much
later than 1876 later than 1976 so I'm
sure the requirements have changed I
also love that the exam says arithmetic
algebra and geometry like math of the
only thing so there is no of course not
there's also no engineering no physics
no chemistry no bio knowledge just math
yeah so I guess an interesting question
would be you know what did you have to
personally do to get into my D you
probably didn't have to do this you know
I didn't have to do so funny I can't
wait until I will show you and I say
yeah I can't wait till you guys see this
example cuz hilarious so we SATs so you
had to take those which had writing math
and reading comprehension and then then
you also to take subject tests so I had
to take the physics subject test which
was not easy and I had to study pretty
hard and specifically for because our
physics classes at my tiny private
school that I went to high school at
will only went up to mechanics didn't go
passed into any NM but there was an M on
this subject test
there was nothing calculus based yeah
just the standardized tests all right so
you really hit I guess had to prove
yourself and you know physics
yes actually get it done again you know
when we show you this exam in 1876 that
was only a few years after MIT came into
existence and I think they just wanted
to see that people had a basic education
and
mathematics and I think it was more you
know there were only a few people that
could maybe afford to go to MIT or or
just you know I had the opportunity to
go so probably a much less competitive
to get in
so maybe the exam reflects that but this
is interesting vocab will show you there
yeah yeah I read this honestly all your
comments are making me wonder like what
what it was like at the time like was it
really I assume a lot of people didn't
know about MIT in the way that they
internationally know about it now or
there just weren't as many people
applying like now people apply from all
over the country and all over the world
so it's a bit more rigorous yeah yeah
all right so this is what the exam looks
like we've got seven questions on here
this is just geometry about having a
little read through them some of them
it's not even quite clear what they're
asking so I'll read you the first
question so if a straight line drawn
parallel to the base of a triangle by
six one of the sides it bisects the
other also and the portion of it
intercepted between the two sides is
equal to 1/2 the base yeah so so where's
the question it's like okay there's not
even a question work or even like a
statement of okay do this now
yeah so I guess the assumption here is
that you have to prove like the latter
half of this but it's interesting that
they don't write proof because they do
actually in these later questions write
prove like prove the side of the regular
inscribed hexagon is equal to the radius
of the circle okay this one is just okay
so first of all it's like they tell you
if this then that and then also this
happens and then also this happens so so
it feels very much like like here's some
statements it doesn't it really doesn't
feel like this is something you should
prove but I can't imagine anything else
you would do with it besides proof I'm
just I'm surprised at how short this is
well I guess okay so there's the
arithmetic algebra and then we're just
on geometry skip number six so yeah
number six of
like something about a polar triangle
whatever that is and then see you figure
on blackboard so I'm missing a bit of
information there but the rest of these
I guess we have enough knowledge to
prove them and it looks like to me it
seems like it's using school concepts
means that I remember doing at school so
having a look at these like I don't
particularly ever remember doing you
know questions like this like defining a
frustum whatever that is yeah but I do
remember I think the laws behind some of
these geometry questions and they're
really basic things like that angles in
a triangle add up to 180 and then you
know angles on a line add up to 180 and
that if you have parallel lines and draw
a line between them the corresponding
angles you get are equal to each other
mm-hmm yeah I mean it's just looking at
number two the diameter perpendicular to
a chord so first of all you have to know
some of these terms like you've to
remember what a chord is and I think I
remember that that just means if you
have a circle and you have a line going
from one part of the circle through the
circle to the other part that's a chord
yeah yeah right yes I think it's it's
tackling vocab here so we've got chord
we've got by six mm-hmm I saw that pop
up yeah by six so that's splitting a
line I think equally half-believed see
10th is not actually eight I
particularly remember but I know I mean
before yeah I did not remember what that
was I thought it was like a Mariner term
yeah maybe that's but I'm yeah although
considering it's from 1876 I think one
thing that is notable is that math
doesn't really change that much so they
are still things that seem doable to me
you know with a modern math education
it's not like fundamentally these
concepts are changing and I think
because you know the questions are
reasonably simple we still can just
figure them out that's pretty
interesting I didn't thought about that
about the fact that this is from 1876
and and even still you know reading this
sentence I understand
basically what they're saying
I don't use the word subtended on a
daily basis but but I can get you know I
can get the point of what they're trying
to say and again like they're just
stating something here but it looks like
something they want you to prove yeah so
yeah if anything it's surprisingly
understandable I actually think that if
we were doing an 1876 English exam oh oh
for sure
I think if we were doing a 2019 English
exam I'd struggle why so let's just
solve a couple of the questions to have
a look at what the answers basically
look like for these things yeah I'm
ready let's do it okay so I'm going to
take charge of solving the first problem
on here and I read it out before but we
will draw a little diagram so we have a
triangle forgive me for my drawing
skills I'm leaning over the track we
have a straight line drawn parallel to
the base and it bisects one other side
so okay we want to come in halfway
between these bisects the other also
sure and the portion of it intercepted
between the two sides is that part was
the most confusing so they just mean I
guess they mean this pod yeah oh yeah
intercepted between the two side that's
not the phrase I would choose to is that
sure the project between on the line
between the two sides
okay that's equal to half of this line
so yeah let's let's draw in a few more
lines to help us out so I'm going to
draw another parallel line through that
tip nice we can put one there as well so
the cool thing about parallel lines that
I remember from school geometry is that
if they're parallel and we have a line
between them then well I think it's the
alternating angles are the same yeah
yeah these ones but then also like these
ones yeah
there's gotta be amazing about that so
it's yeah so it's this angle here and
this angle here like
interior angles yeah are the same so
those are the same and then by a similar
reasoning this angle and this angle here
will also be the same as each other
yep so we can go from there
because this line is equal to this line
and also this line is equal to that line
what we're getting at here is we've got
some similar triangles going on in this
case we have you know this triangle here
would be similar to the larger triangle
so by saying similar I mean that it's
kind of just the same but scaled down a
bit so the ratios between like the sides
and the angles should be the same for
both those triangles so that's what I'm
going to work with to say that if
drawing this line across here has cut
this line in half then because they're
similar and they related by a ratio of
one half then I'm going to think that
applies to this line on the bottom as
well that because they're similar
triangles these lines would be related
by 1/2 so I know I haven't actually
written anything down but I did look up
similar triangles I didn't remember what
the would like the terms of similar
triangle is but it gives you that the
triangles have congruent angles which
means that they have essentially the
same angles but you we're talking about
how you've got these same angles here in
these same angles here and then this is
obviously sharing things but then that
that also means that within a similar
triangle you have proportional sides
okay yeah which is useful yeah so yeah I
think being able to link them by a
factor of 1/2 I guess that answers the
questions I don't know if my 1876
geometry Trudeau would be very happy
with just my thermal reasoning but yeah
that's sort of the approach that I would
take so yeah looks good to me
I'd let you in thank you so um I'm gonna
take over here for Toby and I'm gonna do
number 5 which involves defining the
frustum of a pyramid so I'm gonna
go ahead an admit that I've already
failed this test because I had no idea
what a frustum was I had to look that up
did you know I didn't say we had to look
up some things here but it turns out a
fresh stone for all of you who are along
with us maybe some of you knew what it
was but if you have a pyramid and you
cut the pyramid partway then this sort
of it's this part like yeah yeah if we
remove the tip you've got left is this
kind of I'm pretty impressed with my
drawings okay
so what you've got left is like this
sort of section of a pyramid like the
lower section like you cut off a smaller
pyramid and removed it and then you've
got this left so this is me defining
Rustom yeah you get points for that it
seems because that's just the first part
to find a frustum of a regular beauty
this is amazing there's somebody else to
face but me okay and then define lateral
area also had to look that up but
lateral area is the area of like these
these sides the slanted side so then
there's obviously two more on the other
side but I can't draw this these two
right here and here
so lateral area done check okay and then
prove the next part actually tells you
to prove that's proved that the lateral
area of a frustum of a regular pyramid
is equal to half the sum of the
perimeters of the upper and lower basis
so this is the upper base perimeter and
then this is the lower base perimeter
okay now we're gonna prove oh x the
slant height and then this slant height
is this
this won't do H for the sake of hanging
out with an Australian I'm gonna call it
a trapezoid but we would call a
trapezoid so these are all trapezoids on
the sides and to do the area of the of
these you would you know you could
imagine that you take this little
triangle from this side and move it over
to right there multiply this height by
this base and you get the area of the
trapezoid which turns out to be this
distance here it turns out to be the
average between this distance this lower
part the lower side of the trapezoid and
the top part so we're gonna call this I
don't know we'll call this like the base
and the top so to find the average of
those you do base plus top over two and
then I want to find the area of this
whole thing and that would be H so the
area of a trapezoid I mean the formula
for it ends up being the height sorry
not this
I meant to refer to this height with my
age now we're on the right track this
site is H now we've got the formula for
the area of a trapezoid which is just
the height of the trapezoid times the
base length which is this whole length
here plus the top length over 2 now if
we sum up all of those all four of them
move this over for a second so we've got
all of the all the top links summed and
all the bottom length summed over 2
times a way to look back at what exactly
it was proving which is proof
the sum of the perimeter is the upper
and lower base is multiplied by the
slant height half ism cool
well I've got my half now I've got all
of my all of my top sides and all the
bases
added up but this right here is the top
perimeter these four and then these four
here are the bottom perimeter so we've
got that over 2 times the slant height
and disapprove right yeah I think you've
got it after having to cheat and look up
a frustum yeah now I think we got there
in the end so I guess yeah we've seen
what these answers sort of look like
you've seen us sort of struggle with
vocab yeah but yeah I mean guys feel
free to try some of these questions at
home it's not dangerous and thanks Diana
for joining me in this video thanks for
having me it was a lot of fun yeah so
we're gonna have a look at another MIT
exam over on Diana's channel so you guys
can go and check out that if you want to
we're going to look at physics the first
physics class I took which is called 801
2 which is physics for masochists and
this is the final very shiny and
beautiful and terrifying yeah alright
thanks for watching
you
[Music]